payer des cabinets privés pour gérer des
affaires publiques est ce normal qu est
ce que vous en pensez on vous a posé la
question regarder bon je pense que parce
que nous avons un gouvernement qui est
dirigée par un financier et qui aime
bien faire profiter les grands
entreprises et sans reprise de du
capitalisme voilà c'est vrai que dans
les bus gouvernement précédent mise à
part françois hollande qui n'a pas
utilisé ce genre de choses d'artifice
sarkozy déjà utilisé la preuve en est
c'est que le je crois que monsieur
guillon qui est temps
prison sûrement à cause de ça voilà mais
par contre monsieur macro l'huile et
elissa tapo
n'importe comment il ya un budget un
budget de l'état qui doit se tourner
dans les 310 milliards on est comme ça
bon le pognon est répartie commandes
[Musique]
il ya toujours à l'affût des sociétés
privées qui sont là pour se mettre
là-dedans
je trouve ça un peu idiot dans la mesure
où on a une administration est
extrêmement efficace ça sert à rien de
faire des études administratives et
juridiques si on emploie des cabinets
je pense pas que ce soit des saisons
mais une mauvaise idée dans un pays où à
peu près 80 85 % des doutes de de l'ag
du pays vient du secteur privé donc s'il
ya des talents dans le dans des cabinets
conseil privé je pense qu'il faut les
utiliser
c'est tout simple